hey guys it's justine and uh i'm on my
podcast set up today because i just
recorded one with my sister if you guys
aren't subscribed to our podcast channel
you should go check it out on
youtube.combrain and also subscribe on
apple podcasts
but this video is to talk about the
november 10th event and i know it seems
like
they have had events pretty much every
week at this point but
i mean i'm not complaining at all i
think this is the one though that we've
been waiting for
now it's titled one more thing but i am
kind of hoping that they do show us a
few things
i am very hopeful that they will maybe
launch those rumored airpods studio
and then maybe those air tags i feel
like we keep reading about them
but not actually seeing them it's like
those rumors are suggesting that they're
there
but where are they maybe we could use an
air tag
to find the air tags anyway most of the
rumors are suggesting that this one more
thing event is going to be focusing on
the new silicon max which would make
sense because they did say that they
were going to be launching them
by the end of the year and according to
my calculations on my apple watch
the end of the year is nearing so i have
a feeling that it's going to be a few
things and then maybe
one big or one little surprise at the
end using steve's old catchphrase so i
looked up
the last time they used the one more
thing and it was for the iphone 10.
tim said we have great respect for these
words and we don't use them lightly
i actually remember that and remember
getting very emotional just thinking
about all of the times that steve had
said that and then announced something
incredible
now before that i decided to look up all
of the times that one more thing was
used to announce a product so before the
iphone 10
it was actually in 2015 to launch apple
music
and then it was 2014 for the apple watch
2011 for itunes match
2010 for macbook air facetime and 2nd
gen apple tv
in 2009 it was ipod nano and 2008 it was
for the next gen macbook
in 2007 safari for windows in 2006
macbook pro and apple tv do you guys
should i keep going
cause like i definitely i think i'm
gonna keep going but i just don't know
if these are all accurate
i read it on the internet you can't
believe everything that you read on the
internet
but they sound pretty accurate feel free
to correct me in the comments below in
2005 the ipod shuffle
and tv shows on itunes in 2004 the 30
inch cinema display and ipod mini colors
in 2003 a power mac g5 and a 12 inch
powerbook g4 2002 the imac g4 and ipod
with windows compatibility in 2001 it
was the powerbook g4
in 2000 the new graphical interface
called aqua
and the power mac g4 cube which i
absolutely love this thing
this thing's beautiful look at it it's a
piece of work it's a piece of art and
last but not least in 1999
was apple airport and the 22-inch cinema
display
imac tv and imovie can't believe imovie
was launched in 1999.
that's kind of wild so already this year
apple has announced the 4th gen ipad air
the 8th gen ipad the apple watch series
6 the new iphone 12
the homepod mini and really the last
piece of the puzzle
is this arm-based mac that they've been
talking about since wwdc so apple had
announced that they were going to start
building their own custom chips and
building them in-house
allows them to bring improved
performance and more efficiency to all
of their devices
i mean this really makes sense because
pretty much all of their other chips and
everything
is pretty much made by them so they're
able to custom tailor it to
all of the proprietary software and
hardware i mean i remember the
transition from ibm's power pc to intel
back in 2005 when steve announced this
huge change over at wwdc now this was
really big news at the time and it did
take quite a while for all of the
devices to switch over i think in the
keynote they said that they were trying
to get the turnover of all of their
computers to apple silicon
in the next two years which would kind
of make sense but it's actually
not that much time really if you think
about it so the rumors that i've read
about this event are saying that the
first two apple silicon macbooks will be
a new 13-inch macbook air and a 13-inch
macbook pro and then there's also rumors
saying that there's gonna be an imac
that's set to release in 2021
along with the return of a 12-inch
macbook we've seen so many rumors about
a 14-inch macbook that i'm
hoping that that'll be the one more
thing i mean is that what i want the one
more thing to be
i'm not sure if i do but it has been
talked about and widely ruined for quite
a while
so maybe it is i just feel like it's
gonna be something else i just don't
think that's gonna be the one more thing
i've also become so used to working on
my 16-inch macbook that the 13s
almost feel like i'm using an iphone i
just love having the power and the extra
screen real estate
and honestly the amount of stuff that i
edit on that macbook
i'm just thinking about it and i must
say justine
pat on the back i'm impressed so another
rumor
that i saw that was kind of cool is that
they might actually be working on a
smaller version of the mac pro
like half of the size but i honestly
don't think that i could have been able
to put out nearly as much content that i
have this year
if it wasn't for working on that mac pro
it is so fast so efficient
that i'm able to do so many different
things without even making a dent in the
processing power that this thing has
it is super impressive i think i really
probably should do a follow-up video on
how i'm loving this thing
but i feel like it kind of goes without
saying anyways i'm super hyped for the
event and i cannot wait
as always it's also kind of crazy
because apple has
zero chill on their launch date because
november 10th is also the launch of the
xbox consoles
so it is gonna be a very exciting day in
tech
so i will see you guys back here
probably tomorrow for another video
you